>> Laura: IT'S A NIGHTMARE.
THIS IS THIRD WORLD VIOLENCE
HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
YOU BET IT'S CONCERNING.
SO HOW DO WE STOP THIS?
WELL, ON MONDAY, 380 SHERIFFS
REPRESENTING 40 STATES ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY HAD SENT A LETTER TO
EVERY MEMBER OF CONGRESS CALLING
FOR LEGISLATION THAT INCLUDES
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BORDER WALL.
JOINING US FOR REACTION IS THE
SHERIFF WHO SPEARHEADED THAT
LETTER, BRISTOL COUNTY,
MASSACHUSETTS, SHERIFF TOM
HODGSON, AND ALSO A FORMER
DEPUTY PRESS SECRETARY FOR THE
DMC, IN MIAMI.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO BE
HERE IN STUDIO WITH ME, NOW YOU
ARE IN MIAMI.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE, IT
IS A STICKY ISSUE, A
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE, SHERIFF,
LET'S START WITH YOU.
380 SHERIFFS -- THERE ARE A LOT
OF SHERIFFS ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
BUT THAT IS NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
NUMBER, SAYING THE BOARD ABOUT
AS NECESSARY.
WE HAVE GOT CONGRESSMEN AND
SENATORS IN WASHINGTON WHO SAY
SENSORS AND PARTIAL DOUBLE
FENCING AND OTHER TECHNOLOGY
DRONES, THAT WILL BE ENOUGH
ALONG WITH ADDITIONAL MANPOWER
TO SECURE THIS BORDER.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THESE ARE
PRETTY WHO SPEND THEIR TIME,
LITTLE IDEA OF WHAT THE TERRAIN
IS AND SO FORTH.
IT'S GOING TO BE -- THERE ARE
GOING TO BE SOME CYBER THINGS,
THERE WILL BE SOME, YOU KNOW,
VISUAL POSTS.
THE WALL IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
TO KEEP PEOPLE FROM GETTING INTO
THIS COUNTRY AS EASILY AS THEY
ARE COMING IN NOW, AND THEY KEEP
FLOODING AND BY THE THOUSANDS,
AS YOU KNOW.
>> Laura: I WENT TO GO TO YOU
ON THIS.
A COLUMNIST FOR
"THE NEW YORK POST" WROTE A
PIECE LISTING THE ILLEGAL ALIENS
WHO WERE CAUGHT AT THE BORDER,
AND THIS IS BACK IN THE YEAR
2015, AND WE ARE NOT TALK ABOUT
MEXICANS OR GUATEMALANS OR
SALVADORANS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE FROM
COUNTRIES THAT WERE LABELED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA AS TERROR
HAVENS.
THIS IS WHAT THEY FOUND IN 2015.
BORDER PATROL DEFENSES DETAINED,
FROM IRAN, 154, SUDAN, 81,
SYRIA, 57, AND FROM CUBA, THEN
DESIGNATED A TERRORIST COUNTRY,
2,281, AND THEN COUNTRIES OF
INTEREST INCLUDED AFGHANISTAN,
ALGERIA, IRAQ, LEBANON, NIGERIA,
PAKISTAN, SAUDI ARABIA, 276.
SMALL, 131.
YEMEN, 71.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, IS IT NOT, AT THE BORDER?
>> IT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE, LAURA, BUT WE HAVE TO BE
CLEAR OF SOMETHING, AND IT IS
THIS.
THE ONLY WAY THAT WE ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO SOLVE IT, THE
ONLY WAY WERE ACTUALLY GOING TO
GET THE REAL CRIMINALS, LET ME
BE CLEAR, ANYBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO IS UNDOCUMENTED AND
HAS COMMITTED SERIOUS CRIMES,
THEY HAVE TO BE DEPORTED BY THE
WAY WE DO THAT IS BY TACKLING
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
THAT'S ACTUALLY GET THE
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
GOOD PEOPLE, LET'S GET THEM OUT
OF THE SHADOWS, LET'S MOVE THEM
TOWARDS THE SYSTEM, THAT WOULD
ALLOW PEOPLE LIKE THE SHERIFF TO
ACTUALLY GO AFTER THE BAD GUYS.
>> Laura: SO IT --
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT TO DO.
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THE UNITED STATES
OR IN THE SHADOWS?
BECAUSE I SEE THEM AT RALLIES, I
SEE THEM AT PROTESTS, I SEE THEM
AT CONGRESSMAN'S OFFICES, I SAW
THEM AT THE STATE OF THE UNION.
I DON'T SEE THEM -- THEY'RE
OUTSIDE OF WALMART, THEY ARE
GETTING JOBS, THEY ARE WORKING,
SOME ARE DACA MEMBERS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT IN THE SHADOWS ANY
LONGER.
MOST OF THEM, I DON'T THINK.
>> THEY ARE CERTAINLY IN THE
SHADOW OF THE ECONOMY, EVEN
THOUGH THEY PAY TAXES, RIGHT?
>> Laura: NOT MOST PAY TAXES.
>> A LOT OF THEM DO THOUGH.
YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF THEM DO.
A LOT OF THEM DO.
>> Laura: JOSE, YOU AND I
WOULD AGREE THAT A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS ARE ABUSING THESE
IMMIGRANTS.
THEY ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THEM.
>> BY PAYING THEM VERY LITTLE
MONEY, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: THEY ARE ENDANGERING
THE LIVES OF A DATE AND MAKE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY CAN GET A JOB.
THAT IS ENDANGERING THEIR LIVES.
LET ME GO BACK TO THE SHERIFF.
WE'LL GO BACK IN ONE SECOND.
SHERIFF, HEARD WHAT JOSE SAID,
WHAT WE NEED, COMPREHENSIVE
REFORM.
THIS WALL IS A WASTE OF MONEY,
PEOPLE CLIMB OVER ANY WALL.
YOUR REACTION?
>> YOU WILL NOT HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM UNTIL YOU
DEAR DEAL WITH SECURITY, NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN.
THIS IDEA OF PEOPLE COMING OUT
OF THE SHADOWS AND YOU NEED THEM
TO REPORT CRIME, THAT IS A FALSE
NARRATIVE.
MORE TO THE POINT IS, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO ARE PRO-SANCTUARY
STATE SAYING, GET THEM OUT OF
THE SHADOWS, GIVE THEM A
PROTECTIVE BUBBLE SO NO ONE CAN
IDENTIFY WHO THEY ARE, AT THE
SAME TIME, YOU'VE GOT TO BECERRA
IN CALIFORNIA SAYING, YOU
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS, YOU
BUSINESS OWNERS, IF YOU DARE TO
NOT COOPERATE WITH I.C.E., -- IF
YOU DARE TO COOPERATE WITH
I.C.E. --
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND COMPLETELY
UN-AMERICAN AND UNDERMINES THE
SHERIFFS AND ALL OF THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY WHO ARE
TRYING TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY SAFE
TRYING TO KEEP THIS COUNTRY SAF
SAFE.
>> Laura: I THINK ONE THINGS
AMERICANS CAN'T KEEP THEIR MINDS
WRAPPED AROUND, CALIFORNIA IS
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL STATE, I TOOK
THE CALIFORNIA BAR YEARS AGO,
WANTED TO LIVE THERE, LOVED THE
STATE.
BUT IT IS AN ODD THING, IS IT
NOT, WHEN BUSINESS OWNERS,
PAYING A LOT OF TAXES, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY MADE OUT TO BE THE BAD
GUYS WHEN THEY COOPERATE WITH
I.C.E. OR THEY SIMPLY REPORTS TO
I.C.E. OR THEY ALLOW I.C.E. TO
COME IN AND EXAMINE THEIR
WORKPLACE.
THEY ARE THE BAD GUYS, AND THEN
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
RELEASED BACK INTO SOCIETY, THEY
ARE CODDLED, THEY ARE PROTECTED,